Oh
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone this is here in Greenberg from
Team Xbox I'm excited to be coming to
you here live from my kitchen I'm
drinking non-stop drinks out of the
world's fastest most powerful fridge
we're moments away from a huge inside
Xbox first I want to let you know a lot
of people have been wondering what are
we doing this summer well we're not
taking the summer off working hard
teams cannot wait to deliver new games
new reveals new news for you so it's
time to get hyped
you're gonna see today the first ever
Xbox series X gameplay from our partners
around the world
Damon Baker and Sarah Vaughn to leave
our fritter ship team I've brought some
of the best developers and creative
teams to the table they're gonna be
joined by Jeff Katerina and Malik team
Xbox coming in strong it's an exciting
day we know fans have been waiting for
this but also we know you're wondering
what's going on with Xbox game studios
you guys have 15 creative teams now
around the world you blew us away at EXO
19 you blew us away at the game award so
tell play - we know you've got more of
course we do and with that I want to
welcome the head of Xbox game studios
Matt booty - tell us a little more
thanks Erin and hi everybody I want to
start by saying that our first concern
is really with the safety of our teams
and of course their families and that's
why they are all working from home right
now whether it's in Sweden the UK Canada
or the US and I've really been impressed
with the ingenuity and the creativity
that they've shown to get around some of
the challenges of working from home and
to keep production moving forward on our
great lineup of games and so we're
excited that we will begin unveiling
gameplay from our studios starting in
July including some from our newer
studios like double flying ninja theory
and obsidian mat it feels pretty much
might have left some off the list there
yeah and Aaron also 343 and halo that's
right it's time to get hyped halos come
in halo infinite you've been waiting the
world's most anticipated game July
market calendars Xbox game studios we've
got teams
around the world that are working on big
surprises big reveals for you I could
not be more excited I can tell you we're
gonna work every week between now and
then to deliver for our fans but today
we're gonna put the spotlight on our
partners and let them shine and show you
what Xbox Series next gameplay look like
let's have a go
[Music]
you
[Music]
what you just witnessed was bright
memory infinite from play ISM created
from the ground up by a single
individual @f yqd studio in China
developers are using the hardware to
achieve their dreams and their
nightmares in amazing ways using the
power to optimize their games the way
they want you know higher resolutions
crazy frame rates rate racing and yes
faster in game load times but it's also
awesome to see the partners support for
smart delivery ensuring that fans only
have to purchase the game once to enjoy
it on whichever Xbox system they own or
will own in the future so over the next
25 minutes we're going to debut just a
slice of the amazing next-gen games you
can expect from our partners this
holiday and early next year and because
we read the interwebs everything you see
here will highlight the in-game
experience with actual gameplay captured
in engine to give you the best sense of
what to expect when Xbox series X
launches later this year so sit back
relax and enjoy the following dreams
being powered by Xbox
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
together we built order out of chaos
each trial each tribulation we have
overcome now we live in an age of our
unprecedented peace
prepared thanks to her
let her ascension service with
of our righteousness
it is in her honor
please try
[Music]
this ends with us
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up everybody
thanks for letting me crash the show
this is Patrick mahomes quarterback for
the Super Bowl champion Kansas City
Chiefs
I hope all y'all been staying home
staying safe and playing a ton of video
games together but hey I'm here because
I have the privilege of telling you this
Madden 21 is coming to Xbox series X and
I can't wait to get my hands on it it's
been a journey that's older than me and
I was lucky enough to be a part of it
this year like they say you have to know
where you've been to know where you're
about to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
waiting to the trying 12
[Applause]
there's loads of man 21 News coming soon
and the game isn't just about what you
can see it's about what you can feel but
here's the best news when you buy Madden
NFL 21 on Xbox one you get it free on
Xbox series X I'm looking forward to it
and honestly I'm ready to just get back
on the field enjoy the rest of the show
and get ready to fill next level with EA
Sports
[Music]
huge thanks to EA for giving us that
sneak peek at Madden 21 optimized for
Xbox series X I mean I was awesome so my
name is Sarah bond and I lead
partnerships for Xbox which means I get
to work with the thousands of developers
and creators around the globe that are
creating games on with and for Microsoft
platforms I just love my job because
it's all about connecting creators and
publishers with our fans around
something that they love
games and boy have they been busy they
are creating right now games that are
going to define the generation
experiences that are just gonna blow
your mind away and I am thrilled to
share with you that every major
publisher worldwide is developing for
Xbox and we already have hundreds
hundreds of games coming to Xbox series
X in 2021 the support it has just been
tremendous guys I have never seen
partners as excited about Xbox and Xbox
Series X as they are right now so why
don't we take a look and see more of the
great games that they have been working
on
[Music]
[Music]
dr.xu
darling danke Schoen thank you for all
the joy and pain picture show
second balcony was the fresh
meet second seat go Dutch treat
but somehow we still
I would grab a lid
[Music]
your daddy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Harry what have you done I've traveled
so very far to find you you're strange
that your trail ends here
very Island of my dreams
when you left I was withering away
but here on this extraordinary aisle I
daresay I've found my strength again
[Music]
I'm scared of what it means I feel the
call of something deep within whispers
of things long-forgotten
will we be forgotten - what did you find
here Harry
[Music]
this is or was the assent group of a
metropolis like you
most people have contracted their entire
lives away to get here workers index
slaves in all but name
this is a conscious supernova
proved his collapse we have a shot so
independence
total waste we wish to test your
abilities by giving you a special
assignment
it hurts I forgot for together
that's got it
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi hope you enjoyed the review of the
medium our next-gen psychological horror
game we're very excited to announce that
we're working on the project in
cooperation with Akira Yamaoka
the legendary composer best known for
the Silent Hill series we'll have more
to reveal soon so stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm you Ito sumeragi
[Music]
my power is psychokinesis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
in a mug they're not high speed internet
Java shoulder logically still many
tomorrow do that
meet you
all my talk about dengue turn it off
I love you
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
suppose you're my oyster
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ronita and second on that was to show
this yo-yo the killer here are my roster
[ __ ] even fights in fact they are yeah
like waaah drama oh look she did not own
title post a force textbook Vanya a
Windows 10 day I have a through a
Commodore Perry master second dismay
hajimete a canal title or telephone cat
anymore
Thomas indeed Alex tenant you who need
tonight there it was game no game Kaito
Fame through yoga italiano a lot
honorable so say no the he totally
theater extent unique invaders yes that
Vera Wang
oh the he your school on the guys once I
hope you all enjoyed this brief peek at
just some of the titles we have lined up
for Xbox series X this is just the
beginning and personally I can't wait to
get immersed in these amazing games but
until then I'm just gonna have to live
out that fantasy buy a custom
backgrounds and Microsoft teams how
about I I try out a few now maybe we'll
go into the world of scarlet Nexus or
maybe I could tear up the streets in
dirt 5 or well here's a quick view of
Phil Spencer's Home Office oh wait a
second we've got this inside look at the
next Assassin's Creed game so with that
I'm gonna leave you with the gameplay
debut of the highly anticipated
Assassin's Creed Valhalla for Xbox
series X huge thanks to all of our
partners for their hard work during
these difficult times and to you at home
for joining us stay tuned to go behind
the scenes with a few of the creators of
today's lineup and hear more about their
thoughts on the next generation of game
development
I'll see you later the summer for even
more content premieres and announcements
from Xbox game studios and our partners
worldwide thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
few titles command the respect and
fandom that the Assassin's Creed series
has garnered and today we get to talk
about Assassin's Creed Valhalla with its
creative director Ostroff Ismail who's
joining us from Montreal Canada
Bienvenue - inside Xbox hey pleasure to
be here I'm so glad that you're here
because I am a huge fan of the series
after seeing the video that we just saw
I have literally hundreds of questions
to ask you but before we get into
Valhalla itself did I just see new
Assassin's Creed game play for the first
time yeah absolutely that was directly
from the game and all its viking-age
glory let's talk about the Viking Age
because Assassin's Creed Odyssey
Assassin's Creed origins these took
place in antiquity they were
sun-drenched Mediterranean places and
this looks very different different time
different place so what do you have for
us with the Viking Age yeah so the the
Viking Age it's named after one of
history's most notorious warrior
cultures and this time period is
highlighted by the invasion of England
by this very large hungry Viking horde
and at the time England was a Dark Age
tangle of broken warring kingdoms so
this was an absolutely brutal pivotal
moment in history that gave us the birth
of the England we know today so players
can expect to fully live the Viking
fantasy in a meticulously crafted
journey in an assassin's creed world all
right so let's let's get a little bit
bored into this there was a lot to take
in and that clip that we saw I saw
Viking longships I saw some very mean
looking axes previously we saw a hidden
blade so let's talk about some of the
key new features that you're bringing to
the table with Assassin's Creed Valhalla
yeah so our hero a war is a Viking
Raider who's going to leave the snowy
mountains of Norway for the lush rolling
hills of England propelled by the goal
of settling their people and growing
thriving settlement now England at this
as a hostile place so to succeed players
will go raiding using their longships
and raiding party they'll assault giant
fortifications and epic battles they'll
have to gain alliances with kings and
legendary Vikings and they'll be faced
with some very harsh choices as the
leader of a community along with that
where we've reinvented combat to be
visceral brutal tons of enemy variety
dual wielding weapons we have a new
fresh take on player progression gear
and weapon systems
we're effectively pushing every single
envelope to deliver this incredible
Viking fantasy all this is music to my
ears thank you so much so this whole
show we've been talking about the Xbox
series that you're talking about next
gen so as a creative director so when
creating a huge epic game how do you
take advantage of this new hardware
well Assassin's Creed has always been
committed to new technologies in order
to push the most immersive experiences
we possibly can and so to have something
like incredibly fast loading times means
that we can remove some of that friction
from the immersion and create a game
that's much more immersive Norway and
Dark Ages England are breathtaking
living worlds so to be able to push them
further to the incredible potential this
is really wonderful for us it's
wonderful for our players and
additionally I'm very happy to confirm
that we are also offering smart delivery
which allows you to purchase the game
once and play it on your Xbox one and
the Xbox Series s that is great news I
think for all the Assassin's fans out
there they'll be able to enjoy it on the
hardware they have now maybe on the
hardware that they are looking forward
to getting later this year thank you so
much a chiropodist melt for joining us
and for sharing the very first details
on Assassin's Creed Valhalla I cannot
wait to see more
absolutely it's my pleasure
[Music]
we have seen so many great games today
showcasing gameplay for Xbox series X so
let's go to Malik right now with Robert
carp from Codemasters to talk dirt five
all right everyone just a few minutes
ago you saw the reveal trailer of dirt 5
and it kind of was left speechless but
I'm gonna have to get it together here
because we're gonna dive even deeper
into everything right now we have Robert
carp who is dirt Bob's development
director in the driver's seat to talk
about what's next for the series Robert
how are you how are you I'm doing great
I'm doing great excited to dive into
this now dirt 5 obviously the newest
game in the series let's start with
locations because kind of the backdrop
is kind of important for a racing game
so where we can be going there 5 so you
saw from the trailer we have New York
then we went to China and then we went
to Norway we've got lots more
environments in that each of the
vironment of bespoke we created based on
real worlds to the tracks and the event
types that we play in there so if you
okay for example you saw us racing over
the East River when it was frozen in
winter but you can play in New York in
the summer and spring and autumn there
you'll be able to race that along River
Island and a couple of different tracks
that gives you totally different
experience after that we go to Brazil we
take in the favelas and Christ the
Redeemer we have tracks in Europe and
Italy in Arizona so there's really a
really wide range of tracks with a
really colorful and wide different color
palette awful really interesting
different experiences super cool I'm
excited to see all the different
locations as well as how the weather's
been changing I'm personally in New York
boys I'm excited to race in New York but
it is a reason game after all so let's
talk about some of the cars that we're
going to be able to jump into we have
one of the widest ranges of vehicles
that we've had in a dope game ever
before
so you've got the running cars that you
saw show some buggies in China we also
have sprint cars which is really cool
and interesting they go around
ovals they only turn left each of their
wheels is like a different size with the
front one on the left the smallest by
calling the way the biggest they've got
900 horsepower and you just basically
drift all the way around the oval kick
your big plumes of smoke which is really
fun
so super cool of course everyone's gonna
be excited for more right more cars more
different types of vehicles that's
pretty cool now let's talk about the
experience when gamers when the players
jump into the game what are some things
that veteran dirt franchise players are
gonna notice and what are some things
that you know they're gonna notice the
first time ever so I think jumping is
the career that gonna no it's just a
kind of agency of the choice of the
different events there's some of the new
things that use the franchise and one of
the ones I'm most excited about is for
player split-screen so in in Korea or in
arcade mode where you can pick your fan
type and your vehicle type and your time
of day how quickly the time changes and
what the weather's gonna change you can
play that with your friends so on launch
day when you get your Xbox series X home
put it up you invite a few friends over
it's always together that's super
exciting for place split-screen
something that we always want to see
because it's always good to have you
friends around and play some games on
the couch that's pretty cool now let's
shift gears a bit into the career mode
obviously your dirt franchise known for
the career mode and taking you through a
bunch of different races can you talk a
bit about the story there and I hear
little birdie has told me that there's a
very dynamic duo and the voiceover booth
let's talk about that as well there is
there is a dynamic era so one of the
things I really enjoyed by the crews of
real world sponsors Sochi race you'll
sign up to real world sponsors will give
you awards and pay you to race for them
and talking you through that will be
your mentor he'll help guide you give
you tips and hints and that's voiced by
Troy Baker greetings from the booth
everybody and there's really only one
person to have as the protagonist
destroy both Jacob emesis and that's
Nolan not thrilled to be working with
Codemasters on this playing a very
pivotal character per usual also you're
gonna see some pretty recognizable faces
in this game so you don't want to miss
it Sochi race do we you'll have to be
him if you want to win the career oh
that's super exciting because one I'm
excited to jump into the career but two
I feel like a lot of players are gonna
be happy about having both troy baker
nolan north in the same video game so
that's gonna be pretty pretty exciting
now again we're super happy that their
five is part of the reveal of the first
gameplay for Xbox series X so let's talk
about some of the
we're going to see that our specifically
Xbox three sex so the five you'll be
able to play a 4k 60fps but they'll also
be an option for a hundred twenty heads
way so you know gamers know forever
accounts 120 Hertz in racing that's
where the actions art on top of that
don't five will leverage the small
delivery technology so you buy the game
on Xbox one you can play on xbox series
X as soon as you get a new console you
buy on Xbox series X and you go over you
have an Xbox one in your house or in
another room and you want to play in
there you can play its box one so you'll
always be playing the best version
lastly it's the fast leveling so that
means you get into the game almost
instantaneously from turning on the
console no more waiting you're in there
you're racing straight away I love
everything that you just said there you
buy the game you get the best version
for the platform that you own you get in
the game loading times are a thing that
everyone hates so minimizing that is
fantastic and then you get to choose
between 4k 60 120 frames per second so
that is pretty cool again Robert thank
you so much for stopping by I got to say
that I probably speak for everyone
watching when there is when I say that
we're super excited to see dirt 5 on
Xbox series X coming up this year thank
you so much for stopping by
alright we've already seen so many games
so far but the trains gonna keep rolling
so we're gonna throw it over to Catarina
who's with the Bluebird team to talk
about medium horror games are a fan
favorite and the medium promises to keep
us guessing in our hearts racing here to
tell us more about the game is jak game
producer from the Bluebird team thank
you so much for joining us Jack hi hello
can you tell us more about this game and
the bloopers team approach to the
psychological horror genre in our first
technological core that was layers of
fear it was the main topic was what can
you sacrifice for your family you can
sacrifice yourself or you need all you
want to sacrifice yourself for the
passion to fulfill yourself and the
second our game it was observer and then
the main topic it was if I'm is still
human if my mind maybe is digitalize or
if I have robotic parts where is
the line you know like in the body
horror stuff and in the Blair Witch of
course there was a wish there was the
forest have that everyone loves bad in
the main topic in the psychological
horror stuff it was PTSD so for the
medium we have like two words in our
game we all was in spirit world we play
as a medium that can see these both
realities so we can think like somebody
can be really good guy but maybe inside
it's not and you when you play as a
medium you have very unique perspective
to find out what is inside other people
and on all what happens in different
places for the medium we heard that you
teamed up with legendary music composer
Akira Yamaoka can you tell us more about
that partnership and how that influenced
the game yeah he's he's the best now of
course for for composing the music for
Silent Hill series and what was most
important for us it was his work on
Silent Hill 2 because 72 for most of our
team is the best horror game ever and
it's one of our main references when we
think about atmosphere in the medium
because we know in one way his music is
you know heavy disturbing oppressive and
in other way it came in nostalgic
emotional and melodic and to bump it up
more that we cooperate but here with our
composer arkady ostrovsky that create
our others scores for our other games
and mix these two approaches together to
fill up our two worlds and our different
points of view so it was really it is
and it was a really great fun this game
is really characterized by those two
worlds can you talk to us more about
this story and and these two worlds and
how the players can look forward to that
yeah so you play as a Mary Ann and she's
a medium and like she can cope with this
that she can she goes or that she can
see the spirit world the second world
but she's like haunted by really one
specific vision that she tried to solve
and she has some kind of the hint that
the answers can be in abandon
communities vacation resource is like a
old hotel so she got her and then she
need to you know find out how the vision
is connected with displays and what that
mystery is there and there two words
came up because our real world and our
real world setting it's like it's Poland
Laden eighties Krakow Krakow is very
important city for fallen history it was
a city of kings and this of course city
of Bluebell we have company here in
relief you will build of the city and
you know it is it's a free Poland in
that time but because in the 80s and
before we live under the regime from a
noose regime and there was like no free
free of speech there was a ring was
censored and when you play as a medium
you have this unique opportunity to see
even further than normal people because
you see the spirit world and spiritual
is like dark mirror of our world like
when all your like anger urges secrets
are reflected there so it also hostile
world in some way so only medium can
like you know solve some puzzles some
mysteries and survive that kind of
encounter horror and is really a genre
that can really take advantage of some
very immersive gameplay what are some of
the Xbox series X features that the
Bluebird team has harnessed to make sure
that you can deliver this epic next-gen
title with the medium yeah of course
first of all it's the horsepower is a
hardware so having that powerful stuff
as a foundation for our game that is
awesome because we spent a lot of years
to thinking about this game how we can
fulfill our dreams about it but we have
a problem with the platform like
everything we thought it's too weak to
fulfill our vision but then Xbox series
X came up and we thought yeah this is
perfect much for us and now a lot of
doors were open for us to be get
creative and do the game as we want it
and like the second most important stuff
is the seamless gameplay like you know
the study fps and no loading screens
because you know you have like immersive
horror cinematic experience and you have
two worlds you can travel between them
you can travel between them in Qatar
between the levels and the whole distort
and whole story and not having any of
you know loading screens and any FPS
drops is like awesome and of course we
use Xbox series X in different ways and
in many different ways but I will leave
this maybe more for the future so stay
tuned guys I think I speak for all the
fans when I say that I'm super excited
to play the medium when it launches on
the Xbox series X thank you so much for
joining us today Jack also thank you
very much I want to give a special thank
you to all of our developers from around
the world who pulled out all the stops
to share this first look at Xbox series
X gameplay with all of you today it's
also great to see how many developers
are taking advantage and leveraging
things like smart delivery really
putting our fans first
and of course we're doing that with all
of our xbox game studios titles and as I
said we're not taking the summer off
today is just the beginning it's time to
get hyped because in July its Xbox game
Studios world premieres reveals lots of
news market calendars will see you there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you